RESTRICTIONS THAT WILL BE LIFTED
HERE IN THE LONE STAR STATE.
SANDRA?
>> Sandra: CASEY STEGALL,
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE RACE TO FIND A VACCINE FOR
COVID-19, SOME ARE SAYING THERE
IS A CONTROVERSIAL A AND INJECTI
ADULTS WITH LIFE CORONAVIRUS
PROVIDES MORAL DILEMMA.
JOINING US AS A FAMILY AND
EMERGENCY MEDICAL PHYSICIAN AND
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS.
ONE ON INJECTING HEALTHY PEOPLE
WITH A VACCINE, JUST FIND A
VACCINE.
YOU HAVE HEALTHY PEOPLE ALL OVER
SLING, OR IF THEY TESTED
POSITIVE FOR THE ANTIBODY THING,
USE ME, USE ME TO HELP FIND A
VACCINE SO WE CAN GET OUT OF
THIS.
>> IT’S GREAT THAT WE HAVE LOTS
OF VOLUNTEERS BUT YOU HAVE TO
REMEMBER, SANDRA, IT TAKES 10-15
YEARS.
THAT’S AN EXTRAORDINARILY FAST
PACE TO GET IT DOWN TO ONE AND
HALF YEARS.
VACCINES HAVE TO GO THROUGH
TRIALS, PHASE ONE, PHASE TWO AND
PHASE THREE.
TWO DOCTORS REPORTED IN THE
JOURNAL OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES,
INSTEAD OF USING THE REGULAR
PHASE THREE TRIAL LET’S USE WHAT
IS CALLED THE HUMAN CHALLENGE
TRIAL.
MEANING AFTER WE CHECKED FOR
SAFETY, EFFECTIVENESS AND DOSAGE
INLETS INJECTED STRAIGHT INTO
PATIENTS.
THE QUESTION IS WE ARE KNOWINGLY
ASKING VOLUNTEERS TO INJECT
THEMSELVES WITH A DEADLY
PATHOGEN THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
KILL THEM.
ON TOP OF THAT WE ARE SEEING SO
MANY PATIENTS, YOUNG PATIENTS
WITH HEART DISEASE AND, AND IT’S
A BIT OF AN ETHICAL DILEMMA THAT
WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION.
>> Sandra: VERY IMPORTANT
DEVELOP IT THERE.
COVID-19 ALTERED TO WORLD
HISTORY AND IT’S NOW EVIDENT
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH AS PART OF
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THAT SAFETY AND SOVEREIGNTY.
THE FIRST COUNTRY TO REACH THIS
PRIZE WILL BE THE FIRST NATION
TO RECOVER.
AND THAT’S 18 MONTHS OUT.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ALL ABOUT THIS
POSSIBLE NEW TREATMENT, THE
HEARTBURN DRUG THAT WE ALL KNOW,
PEPCID.
WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH THAT,
NOBODY IS SAYING TO RUN OUT AND
BUY THIS IF YOU ARE SUFFERING
FROM SYMPTOMS OF COVID-19.
WHAT IS THE EFFECT ON VIRTUAL
PATIENTS?
AND THAT’S AN OVER-THE-COUNTER
MEDICINE.
SO THERE IS A STUDY SHOWING THAT
IF PATIENTS ARE PUT ON
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, WILL THEY
HAVE A BETTER OUTCOME?
THE REASON DOCTORS GOT THE IDEA
TO RUN THE STUDY IN THE
UNITED STATES IS BECAUSE IN
CHINA DOCTORS NOTICED THAT
PATIENTS WHO ARE PUT ON SOME ODA
DEAN VERSUS A MORE EXPENSIVE
AND ANTACID, OUTLIVED THOSE PUT
ON THE MORE EXPENSIVE ANTACID.
BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS
FAMOTIDINE WHICH IS ALSO KNOWN
AS PEPCID ACTS AS A DECOY FOR
THE VIRUS.
SO WHEN IT ENTERS THE SYSTEM IT
INTERACTS AND WON’T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPLICATE.
IT’S BEING STUDIED, DEFINITELY
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT AND IT’S
BEING GIVEN IN VERY HIGH DOSES
IN THIS TRIAL THAT’S GIVEN HERE
IN NEW YORK.
IT’S NOT A HARMFUL MEDICINE TO
TAKE IN HIGH DOSES SO THAT’S
VERY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE NOT DOING ANY HARM TO OUR
PATIENTS DURING THE STUDY.
BUT WE NEED TO TRY AND SEE WHAT
WORKS AND IF IT’S EFFECTIVE,
THAT’S FANTASTIC.
BUT IT WILL TAKE SOME TIME TO
SEE THE RESULTS OF THE STUDY.
>> AS ALWAYS, ASK YOUR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER ABOUT THAT.
>> SOCIAL DISTANCING WILL BE
WITH US THROUGH THE SUMMER TO
REALLY ENSURE THAT WE PROTECT
ONE ANOTHER AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THESE PHASES.
>> Sandra: WITH A FEW SECONDS
WE HAVE LEFT, LET’S TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE SUMMER IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE AS WE SEE PARTS OF THE
SUMMARY OPEN.
>> I THINK AS EVERYONE ADHERES
TO THE CDC GUIDELINES WE CAN
DEFINITELY OPEN UP SLOWLY AND IN
PHASES.
THE GOAL IS TO PROTECT HIGH-RISK
POPULATIONS AS THE MOST
VULNERABLE.
IT’S VERY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ADHERE TO THE 6-FOOT
GUIDELINES BECAUSE WE DEFTLY
WANT TO TAKE THESE VERY STEPS.